bombelli is the father of complex
numbers okay now everything happens in a
context bombelli was going off what he
read in a nice book so we're back in
both belong in here doesn't look like a
very long life his book published in
1572 was just called algebra first
european to systematically deal with
negative numbers and write down the
rules a negative times a negative is
positive that sort of thing dealt with
complex numbers how to add them how to
multiply them how to subtract them how
to divide them I don't know about square
root so imagine he did yeah so Cardno
saw them as okay we can sort of work
with them but they useless anyway you
know for them some sophistic just an
academic exercise no meaning to it dr.
lee celebrated them and his book was
also notable for its down-to-earth
writing other books including cardano's
were highfalutin academic language i
haven't read it i'm not for taking it
personally but bombelli reacted to that
he did not have a formal mathematical
education at all he was an engineer he
developed an interest in mathematics and
he he liked what he read and brought it
down to earth so a good expositor and
and just a clear thing but with the
complex numbers it's a shame that his
book didn't have greater influence and
that's perhaps partly because it was
published in the year that he died and
he had further material in mind
which never got published but was then
found in 1925 and see if it been alive
to you know to promote it to engage in
the community then this book might have
had more influence because according to
what I've read daemon Euler early in his
mathematical life made conceptual errors
or had conceptual difficulties with
imaginary numbers about what happens
when you multiply two of them you know
they don't obey the laws of multiplying
two real numbers whereas that result
dealt with him so if oiler hadn't read
this then he would have got off to a
better start for more history
I recommend this paper complex and
unpredictable it's not an it's not a
difficult mathematical paper it is by an
academic very equals of a recreational
paper the name comes from the complex
numbers and the probability and the
lovely thing is it gives a lot of the
biographical information it doesn't go
into heavy mathematical detail at all
it's all biography there is so much more
to the lives of those gentlemen that
I've said today and it's very
interesting but also that article
gives a nice demonstration a nice
understandable demonstration of how
complex numbers are essential to quantum
mechanics and I've always been wanting
to seek information about how complex
numbers are essential to whatever and
there it is it's it describes the
double-slit experiment and you know the
probability that a particle will get to
this position and you can't work that
probability out without complex numbers
it's not like I've heard of Electrical
Engineering are where we choose to
represent you know current as the real
number and phase is the imaginary number
or whatever and then it makes our
calculations is yeah that's a choice
that's an arbitrary choice I'm speaking
with very little knowledge here but
that's an arbitrary choice with the
quantum mechanics they could not work
out those probabilities without complex
times it's not just a device to make
things easier so two good yeah that's a
very worthwhile 12 pages of your time to
to be able to communicate something of
that to students there is something in
here students and then check this in at
the young so it's and I said at the
beginning it's in draft at the moment so
if you use the link you can you can read
the draft article once I've done all the
reformatting and and so on then it will
appear in the conference brochure so
there we go that is at the end